faudrait qu'on parle du séminaire sauf
qui a pas erick c'est bon c'est bon
merci
la mise en place à la pca cinq joueurs
mas et passionnante depuis son élection
à la tête de la chambre régionale
d'agriculture
philippe noyau multiplie les voyages à
paris il vient siéger à l'assemblée
permanente des chambres d'agriculture la
représentation nationale du monde
agricole
et comme il veut y défendre son val de
loire il est venu ce jour là avec
plusieurs kilos d'une de ses productions
voilà de quoi normalement
bah oui
mais ce clin d'oeil ne doit pas éluder
l'enjeu essentiel pour philippe noyau à
l'assemblée des chambres on est proche
des élus de la république et des relais
européen
il est crucial de s'y faire entendre
quand on a un gros sujet national à
traiter c'est important que chacun amène
sa pierre à l'édifice et amène ces
problématiques qui peuvent se croiser
avec d'autres régions mais ou pas donc
et on se doit au niveau de l'apc à des
chambres d'agriculture le traité de
n'oublier personne de traiter toutes les
agricultures toutes les spécificités
dont classer les actions toutes les
actions qu'on a réalisé déjà en 2002
suite à la chambre régionale l'enjeu est
souvent l'obtention d'un consensus à
paris il s'agit plutôt de convaincre des
partenaires et quelquefois des opposants
l'un des grands combats du moment est
celui de la réduction des produits
phytosanitaires y compris la fin du
glyphosate saint claude et quand on
parle de sujets très politique c'est la
voie de la pca qui vient au secours de
tous les agriculteurs nous dit une
moindre utilisation des phyto tant que
c'est possible
évidemment qu'on aime on y est favorable
nous ce qu'on ne manquent pas et c'est
le glyphosate est vraiment le le contre
exemple de ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
c'est à dire on ne peut pas du jour au
lendemain à interdire une matière active
sans se préoccuper des solutions qu'on
peut avoir derrière c'est assez
révélateur quand même deux aujourd'hui
du positionnement d'agriculture dans la
société
avec toujours cette pression là qui se
fait souvent excessive
une pression à laquelle philippe noyau
devra faire face pendant les six ans à
venir à la tête de la chambre
d'agriculture centre val de loire